[Música]
quem aqui já foi traído
levantem as mãos e não é só a traição de
amor gente é traição é amiga que paquero
namorado que conta seu segredo íntimo é
o amigo todo mundo só que quando a
traição envolve o amor quando a traição
se tá exatamente com aquela pessoa com
quem você está andando caminhando e
apostando todas as suas fichas ator é
desumana e isso a gente vê todo dia tá
certo o que mais tem são esses crimes
violência em função de traição
a minha vida começou um conto de fadas
enquanto de fadas que nós nos conhecemos
no casamento de amigos queridos
a noiva se demorou duas horas para
chegar nós tivemos bastante tempo de
papear saímos do casamento juntos e não
nos separamos até os 32 anos de casados
nós tínhamos uma família perfeita
reclame de margarina filhos criados
planejando aposentadoria na praia até
que um belo dia o telefone toca e uma
moça me conta seu marido tem uma
namorada foi meu marido nem pensar
eu obviamente que a gesba tamente como
um avestruz
enfiei a cabeça no buraco fiquei com a
bunda de fora e jurei que ele era fiel
ledo engano demorou um tempinho pra ele
se assumir que ele de fato tinha tido
uma fé a fé é mais bonito do que caso
não é caso de polícia coisa já envolve
então ele teve um affair mas eu era a
mulher da vida dele
é óbvio que é onde nós vivíamos na
cidade de interior
tudo que acontecia é nos nossos amigos
era sempre o homem trocar a mulher por
duas de 20 mas nenhuma mulher trocava o
seu homem por dois de 20
isso já era bem preconceituoso
eu por cinco anos
tive muito medo medo de assumir medo de
olhar medo de ir atrás e encontrar
porque quando a gente fuça e mulher tem
uma intuição tá certo você vai atrás
porque a equipe pode ser pouca coisa mas
que tem te e aí eu fui fuçar e descobrir
não ele com uma pessoa e descobrir com
quatro na mesma época viu com licença
assim nós ficamos mais à vontade eu não
corro o risco de quebrar o pé aqui tá
certo
e foi exatamente eu me afundei me
afundei na tristeza e afundei na
depressão porque eu não estava perdendo
o sol passado eo presente com ele eu
estava perdendo meu futuro tudo que nós
vínhamos planejando os 32 anos de casado
e contrariando todas as opiniões e os
conselhos porque o conselho é bom mas de
vez em quando me poupe
não é nem da terapeuta me diziam 'não
você tem que ficar em junho era de
chiang rai
você tem que ficar no interior só não
pode sair daqui eu falava não eu vou
embora e o que eu mais ouvia era velha
de vovô se nada e em são paulo não vai
dar certo só que são paulo pra mim
naquele momento era minha única
alternativa de anonimato
eu precisava e eu fui fugir de mim mesma
fugir daquilo que eu achava o que eu não
queria encontrar
e fui viver sozinha em são paulo a
primeira vez na minha vida que eu fui
morar sozinha e de repente eu comum um
exemplo nossa hora digital
eu descobri internet olha nada a ver viu
nenhuma comparação com a emi o éder é
preciso até dar uns conselhos para ela
porque eu acho que a 78 opções dela lhe
pode ter estragado um pouquinho a
procura e na internet
eu fui eu fiz um perfil no meu perfil
era bem mais simples o meu perfil dizia
que eu era uma mulher madura de valores
ea da independente e que eu não queria
mudar a minha situação atual mas que eu
buscava momentos interessantes que eu
era alta magra tá certo eu eu digo pra
vocês que ainda nem um pouquinho alguns
números mas tudo bem né a gente não faz
conta ninguém usa calculadora não tem
problema
tá certo e eu queria minha busca é um
amigão ante um amigo com o ficante
eu queria uma pessoa decente do bem
então o retorno foi bárbaro bem melhor
do que da emi bem melhor e aí de repente
super deprimida porque eu estava
abandonada sozinha eu me vejo como uma
opção de escolha
o meu ego agradeceu sem sombra de
dúvidas
e aí eu fui fazendo a seleção já
descartando aqueles que moravam muito
longe que é difícil aqueles que tinham
fugido do ensino médio
aqueles que já queriam montar um negócio
comigo eu financiando é o outro que
queria vir da koch china com as minhas
milhas para me conhecer
então a gente vai descartando e eu
achava de verdade pra vocês já que nós
estamos falando de intimidades que eu
nunca encontraria alguém pessoalmente
até que deu deu e nós vamos tomar um
café
era um cara interessante e do café
eu me senti apta em posição de alguma
coisa mais quente doce
no dia seguinte foi bem difícil é o
espelho fiel eu olhava eu falava não foi
você que fez isso e tudo aquilo que você
sempre pregou tudo aquilo que você
sempre fez
você tá ficando louca mas nem vi a
imagem do bom daquele momento
interessante eu falava e ferrou
tá certo foi bom foi bom eu tenho que
assumir foi bom
assustador a ribbon e e aí veio o
segundo
e aí veio o terceiro eo quarto foi tão
bom que eu repetir
e aí a minha terapeuta muito
inteligentemente porque eu tinha
momentos de muita tristeza ainda é ao
mesmo tempo em que eu já tinha o uma luz
no fim do túnel eu tinha toda a minha
vida e não só os 32 anos de vida de
casal de família eu tinha toda a minha
vida que tinha se desmontar tudo e eu
comecei a escrever sobre as experiências
boas e eu comecei a relatar como um
diário e à cada a cada experiência é
óbvio eu tinha momentos e em que a russa
gelada era minha maior companhia
quero que me dava força para sair para
ir atrás e para me sentir viva
só que quando eu tava triste deprimida
eu ia ler aquilo que eu tinha escrito e
eu gostava muito mas era tudo na
terceira pessoa não era eu não era outra
pessoa que estava lhe escrevendo
escrevia ela foi ela fez ela deu ela
gostou eu não eu era uma mera
espectadora até que passado um tempo
é talvez até preservada pela distância
eu contei pra um filho que estava longe
que eu estava escrevendo
ele é escritor e ele foi me manda pra
mim eu quero ler e eu mandei gravar tudo
na terceira pessoa acerta tudo ficção
e aí eu tive que ouvir dele mãe bota
tudo na primeira pessoa por que tudo
isso aqui é você
eu só que minha auto-estima era tão
baixa é e eu era tão má gina descrente
de mim forma magina ele ele vaticino vai
dar um livro um livro um livro imagina
não vai dar
só que ele editou ele botou fogo e de
repente nós vamos com um blog 32 um
homem para cada ano que passei com você
e em seis meses de blog no ar
o livro uma editora nos procurou para
publicar porque aí eu tenho 60 anos mas
não tenho prazo de validade nem meu
corpo e muito menos o meu tesão desculpa
ninguém falou que meu corpo que já era
teu pará
tá certo e desculpa é eu acho que é uma
situação em que se eu perguntar agora
para o homem o homem macho é todo pai
transa
verdade ou mentira não houve verdade e
mãe transa a a mãe e avó porque eu tenho
idade para ser avó voto também não eu
transo e gosta
até não tenho vergonha nenhuma de dizer
tá certo e aí a editora quando foi
publicar o livro é resolveu homenagear
como não podia deixar de ser
simone de pavor na capa só que são capas
fotografadas de mulheres reais traídas
voluntárias que elas estão de bunda de
fora
a capa do livro é linda aliás também
está certa é linda porque porque é a
idéia era representar a verdade e o
assinar o livro foi uma luta eu vou
botão pseudônimo vai virar a ficção
ficção qualquer um pode escrever é um
homem até um homem pra falar de das
aventuras da mulher e eu falei não eu
acho que agora é hora de eu encerrar
esse ciclo de fechar minha vida eu fiz o
que eu queria e assinei isabel dias de
verdade
na semana do lançamento do livro a folha
de são paulo fez uma matéria sobre o
livro que foi a notícia mais lida do
jornal durante a semana toda
e aí no na nos dias do lançamento também
chamada de capa da isto é da veja da
época fui pra televisão quer dizer
apareci e foi só aí que os meus amigos
lado interior souberam pois é tá certo e
eu tive amigas que no facebook me
deletaram uma tela seletor nossas fotos
de infância pequenininha lá também
porque eu passei a ser má companhia
sorry a outra não há outra eu até sentir
ela diz que cada vez que ela me via no
facebook eu estragava na cara
dela a vida que ela estava vivendo e eu
senti por ela e pela falta talvez de
coragem
a descoberta do que eu poderia a
descoberta é do meu filho me dizendo que
eu poderia me assumir me fez outra
pessoa absolutamente outra pessoa
eu tenho medo eu morro de medo eu tô
aqui morrendo de medo não sei como eu
consegui tirar o sapato na frente de
tanta gente por que tirar o sapato é o
primeiro admirar né gênios
então eu tirei o sapato mas vou esconder
tá agora ao mesmo tempo eu tive muitas
críticas muitas várias como se as
pessoas me perguntassem porque eu estou
usando meu corpo do jeito que eu quero
que não é o meu direito e quando a gente
vai ficando mais velha o corpo passa a
ser a sociedade todo mundo quer
controlar o cumprimento do meu vestido o
tamanho do meu decote
tá certo o corpo é meu então para
aquelas pessoas que não ficaram felizes
com a minha ação que está cheio de gente
eu só posso dizer que eu sinto muito
porque eu estou só começando
[Aplausos]